[Music]
hey guys welcome to my podcast
congratulations
crazy
[Music]
yeah dude and we're off and we are off
look guys
uh i just want to take a moment to thank
you
uh the subscribers of the patreon uh it
has been
very uh there's been a swell of support
and i want to thank you guys for that
it's
really really great and um it makes me
feel great
uh and if you're not joined then get
involved i don't know what to tell you
but sign up for our patreon
there's [ __ ] you're missing out on okay
um there are uh
uncut episodes hidden episodes and all
that also
something else that would help us out is
if you hit the
like button now if i was a jackass i
would say
hey it's your boy crystalia smash that
like button but i don't do that
because that's [ __ ] behavior so what i'm
saying is
press the like button just look at that
little button down there
and just press it and another button you
could press is the subscribe button
smash that subscribe smash that like
button but don't do that
just gently gently subscribe to the
podcast
just gently graze up against that
subscribe button do you understand what
i'm saying
so do those two things for me please and
it would really help thank you very much
and uh
oh yeah here's another one turn on those
[ __ ] bell notifications
so you know when the episode drops right
so so
there's pretty much three buttons you
should smash
okay there's the subscribe button
that i want you to [ __ ] smash and
then there's the like button i want you
to smash i want you to stop the video or
just do it while you're doing it right
now just a little
smash that like button smash the
subscribe button
and then do me a favor and watch go over
to that bell notification
uh button i want to smash that bell
notification mine but i don't want you
to actually smash it i want you to graze
lightly up against that subscribe button
i want you guys lighting up against that
that that like button and i want you to
just kind of carefully look saunter on
over to the
notification button i just kind of want
you to breathe up against that bell
notification
[Laughter]
so anyway dude that would help us out a
lot and if you don't want it you don't
want him it's free conch
um so we're having a good time
and it's me and that's it so i don't
know why i say we but i say we do it
um and my jaw hurts
my jaw hurts dude and cut to the gif of
[ __ ] antonio banderas
closing his laptop and just going
my jaw hurts
and sort of benders with the [ __ ] 90s
hair
that [ __ ] jerry curled [ __ ] he looked
like an extra and [ __ ] uh
coming to america racist anyway dude my
jaw hurts and that's great dude
my jaw [ __ ] hurts so bad because i've
got tmd
now i thought it was called tmj but when
i went to the dentist today
he said you mean tmd and i said well
what's tmj and he said the [ __ ]
um joint j stands for joint i was like
oh what's d
stand for he said dysfunction so you got
that tmj which is t
stands for something and the mandibular
joint
total mandibular dysfunction um
it hurts and then guess what my [ __ ]
socket is out
i had to get a a a bite plate made
um which is really cool when you're 41
and you need to wear a
bite plate at night
and uh so my my [ __ ] the cartilage
slipped slipping out a little bit jaw
won't open 100
so much pain in my jaw and not only that
in my neck
and not only that behind my eye
[ __ ] yeah dude we got pain in my jaw we
got pain
in my neck and behind my eye
[Music]
dude it wouldn't be cool it wouldn't be
cool to only have one piece of pain in
your head
um so i have three
so [ __ ] come on man who's got the
best [ __ ] pain in their face
me uh i challenge anyone on that dude
uh oh yeah and then this [ __ ] we got
this [ __ ] the wall's back dude
i [ __ ] closed it you know why i
closed it dude you know i closed the
curtains
cause i want to see which [ __ ]
were gonna [ __ ] about it that's why i
want to close the curtains i want to see
people say
dude why'd you do that why'd you do that
a lot of you guys liked the curtains a
lot of you to be honest i thought wait
way more people like the curtains than i
thought
and then people like why did you do that
man you're the og you had the wood wall
first
don't be a [ __ ] and then some people
like oh you changed a good thing why you
fit why'd you change a good thing
oh yeah well guess what [ __ ] i
just wanted you exposed
dude i just wanted you exposed
boom i kind of kept the curtains a
little bit though because a lot of
people said they like the curtains but
uh
anyway dude like i said man i gotta work
on this [ __ ] like i talked about last
episode on the angry olympics dude i got
to just chill like i learned how to
chill
you know yeah i [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
ugh i hate that about myself sometimes
man
like kristen was talking to me about
something earlier and she was just like
what tv are you talking about and i go
like this the one up here
and she's like which what is that and i
point i just pointed up
she's like the one up there i said the
one up there and she was like which one
are you talking about and i said guess
and she was like jesus and i'm like ah
i know
i'm sorry i'm me i try to fix it but
it's so hard when your jaw hurts you
know
because then with me i'm like the kind
of guy that's just like yeah but my jaw
hurts
and like my lips are chapped so i
deserve it
i deserve being rude
i deserve to let myself feel this rage
it's the only emotion you can really
control
sadness hits you like a [ __ ] ton of
bricks but the anger you can control
it's the truth man you're never actually
angry
angry is what you get because you can't
[ __ ] control the other [ __ ] so you're
like oh i'm sad
[ __ ] it i'm angry you know what i mean
you're like oh you're gonna break my
heart all right cool hold on one second
i'll be right back
[ __ ] you like you're never [ __ ] you
you're sad
what happened oh my [ __ ] my best
friend died
of an overdose hold on one second
shouldn't have been taking those [ __ ]
drugs that piece of [ __ ] i always
[ __ ] told him not to
that's what you [ __ ] go to anger's
never the primary emotion
i learned that in therapy
it's all good saving my life um
literally
dude i got chapstick i'll tell you
something it makes me mad i got
chapstick it's this [ __ ] chapstick
and it's thick as [ __ ] and when i put it
on
there's always some jackass that's like
is that a glue stick no it's not dude
it's my [ __ ] chapstick and it's cool
as [ __ ]
anyway dude my jaw [ __ ] hurts man
it's probably cuz that chapstick is so
[ __ ] big but um
yeah so i went to the dentist and uh
i went to the dentist and smashed that
like button anyway
uh speaking of [ __ ] anger dude
sometimes people think i'm angry i'm not
even [ __ ] angry
my my uh i posted a tick tock dude your
boy's been real active on tick tock and
guess what
that's it i'm a tick talker i'm a
[ __ ] tick tocker
and i do some funny tick tock sometimes
and sometimes i oh dude i love the
comments on them man
i love people meet and make friendships
in the comments and then get married
probably
because they both find oh you're you're
dumb too and um
so i did it i did a tick tock video
where i did where you can start it
a video you can have a video there's a
video there's already a video
of a tick tock for those of you that
don't know tic toc and then you can
take that video and add your own ending
to the video
and i'm like this is great for me i can
just fire off
how dumb the videos are with my ending
do you know what i mean
so there was one video of a
two women that take this mosquito net
they're in their bedroom
they take this mosquito net and they put
it over
themselves and they go to bed and it was
for it was an ad for this mosquito net
and i ended the and i stopped in their
videos after their video i put my ending
to the video and i
said hey guys just close your [ __ ]
windows you idiot
you know you don't what an unnecessary
piece of [ __ ] garbage
what the [ __ ] do you need that they're
in their bedroom dude
oh these blasted mosquitoes
close your close your door
hey what about walls
you got them do you have walls
you've got walls you've got mail
remember that [ __ ]
when and then it would be like bile's
done after you're recording [ __ ]
after you're downloading porn
[Laughter]
dude you'd just be like in your [ __ ]
parents office just like let me just
[ __ ] download this jeff
there this [ __ ] jpeg right here
[ __ ] let me just download this jpeg
[ __ ]
tits.com
oh here it comes cool all right cool
nobody's gonna know
this is great bile's done oh god damn it
chris what what's biles done
the gra the [ __ ] audio was so bad it
would be bile's done
files done
dude have the guy record it with the f
harder files done
um anyway dude so i did the [ __ ]
thing
my own ending on the video and i wrote
just close the door you [ __ ] window
you [ __ ] idiots
and then like a minute later it was like
your tic tac goes against
[ __ ] community guidelines and i was
like what
because the two ladies were asian in the
bed so i was like is this a hate crime
i didn't understand and they were like
it got flagged and took off for
bullying dude bullying
it's a [ __ ] ad it was an ad
for a mosquito net an indoor mosquito
net
they took my [ __ ] off for bullying first
of all
i'm joking second of all it was an
ad dude how do you bully a [ __ ] ad
this is where this country and this
world is headed by the way
this is where it's headed
how do you bully an ad
that's like bullying it's like being
it's like bullying cereal
bullying kellogg you can't bully a
[ __ ] product
it's a thing got no brain
it's got no feelings dude we're already
on our way
to bullying products how insane is that
no no no i saw a video the today
just listen to this i texted it to my
friends
oh that's sweet my buddy texted me and
he asked me
how i was and you'll never know who it
is
and that's very sweet uh we like when
that happens so look but let me
let me let me uh play this for you is it
in this one or was it the other one
no it wasn't that one it was in the
other text chain here it is here
dude this is a real thing that somebody
said and meant it
we have quiet rooms that are available
there's a range of options of these
right
please don't go in that space with
anything that's like an aggressive scent
we have quiet rooms that are available
there's a range of options of these
right
please don't go in at space with
anything that's like an aggressive scent
this is at a [ __ ] what do you call it
like a it's in a
a town hall thing like a
like a [ __ ] a big theater and they're
like talking about how people should be
certain ways it's probably out of
college or some [ __ ] and the guy's got
an ascot on obviously
but he says like don't go we have spaces
and don't go to an uh
into spaces with an aggressive [ __ ]
scent
like first of all what's an aggressive
okay and i don't mean like i don't know
what i think an aggressive scent is
i do know what i think in aggressive
sentence but how do i know
what you think an aggressive sentence
if i just go look honestly
any scent is aggressive in my book for
real if you put on one piece of perfume
or one piece of cologne aka perfume
that's aggression
i don't like it get out of my safe space
okay
but does that mean that i'm going to
tell people what to wear or what not to
wear
uh with
when it comes to spraying their shits
yes it does i will tell them what to do
but if they say no i go like this dude
i [ __ ] like your style because you do
you
in this same [ __ ] video and the same
thing people were talking about
there was this town meeting in this town
meeting whatever the [ __ ] i was college
thing whatever the [ __ ] it was
but they were talking about how guys
there's a lot of chatter and i just want
to stand up i get triggered by the
chatter can we not chatter bro
you how about you change how about that
how about you change how about not
everybody in this room full of a
thousand people has to change
how about you church how about the fact
that we don't believe you
that it triggers you and it triggers
your anxiety
when you're voluntarily talking
into a microphone in front of 1 000
people
you know what i'm talking about you
can't expect the world
to cater to you you can't expect the
world to change to you
because dude not everybody gets a
[ __ ] participation trophy
after the age of 12.
dude i was 12 i got to participate
participation pophie
and i and i thought and i i thought it
was bullsh even when i was 12.
i played tennis dude and i played tennis
with the dickens dude
i played good man i got most improved
one year
but the year after that i got [ __ ] mr
hustle
and you know what mr hustle was it was a
participation award
because [ __ ] everybody's hustling
you're trying to go get the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you find out oh who got mr hustle
last year oh [ __ ] dion
oh [ __ ] mark oh these [ __ ]
aren't athletic i'm a [ __ ]
i got mr hustle i knew it was [ __ ]
when i got mr hustle
you participated who gives a i knew as a
12 year old
who gives a [ __ ] you're 30 talking about
how you trigger
people are whispering how about when
they're yelling dude
how about when they're in your face
yelling like the real world then what
you get triggered your mommy's gonna die
one day
your mommy's gonna die then what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do after that
scream out mommy to who people don't
give a [ __ ] if they're not your mommy
that's all i'm saying
dude it's so [ __ ] like just [ __ ]
whatever i don't even mean to say man up
but person the [ __ ] up dude
just say man up because i want to
trigger people so not this one
oh it's just like [ __ ] man
crazy [ __ ] dude the guy was
like hi
he was like whatever he was like i'm
paul he him um
i i just want yeah dude here how about
this man
if you just look like a dude with a dick
and like
you're bald and have hair a beard
we're good dude you don't have to tell
me he am
how about that and if you identify as a
woman go for it
then tell me she her tell me tell me she
her
and you know what i'll be like okay
ma'am
cause i don't give a [ __ ] that much i
don't care
but if you're just some dude that looks
like he plays video games and has a mega
death t-shirt on
dude i guess he him
like if you're a dude that eats funyuns
you don't have to tell me [ __ ] he him
funyuns dude goddamn morgan doy zaki
used to eat funyuns in my high school
that [ __ ] smelled bonkers bad
what the [ __ ] would eat funyuns dude
funyuns are the worst [ __ ] things
ever
they're like rings funyuns dude
i don't like you know this if you listen
to the uh podcast i don't like when the
when they take two words and they put
them together it's not cute dude try
harder
you just took two words and put them
together it's not clever
funyuns gross man
fun you know what i don't trust you know
what i don't trust
candy that gets better as you ease it as
you eat it
that's what i don't trust i want that
[ __ ]
banging from jump no i'm talking about
you take a reese's you put that [ __ ] in
bang and it's a party in your mouth
immediately
that [ __ ] is flavor central immediately
starburst banging twix
banging skittles banging
hot tamales the [ __ ] out of here you
gotta eat like 12 of them and then
do your mouth's on fire and you're like
okay i'm getting into it
i'm talking about
gross dude good and plenty [ __ ] you dude
i want it banging
immediately gushers um
when you put a gusher in your mouth your
head explodes
into a gusher immediate
banging taste
what was the one that stored all this
funyuns dude you gotta eat like 12 of
those [ __ ] things
and then you're like okay i guess i'm
getting into it i guess i'm getting into
it when people say [ __ ] is an acquired
taste
guess what that means bad
[Laughter]
if i have to work to get the taste good
you failed candy guy
if i was a candy maker and somebody said
my candy was an acquired taste
that's the most [ __ ] [ __ ] ever too by
the way this would say it's an acquired
taste
no dude no dude it's an acquired taste
you have to learn to like it
we're humans dude
just put that [ __ ] in your mouth put it
in your mouth
like [ __ ] what's his name on lethal
weapon
danny lover when he said put it in your
mouth
anyway dude my jaw's been hurting the
whole time so that's great it's the jaw
hurting episode
um so yeah dude that's i just i
[ __ ] one time my friend went yeah but
morgan ozaki used to eat the [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] funyuns man
and then one time i i see like candy
like starburst and [ __ ]
fruit by the foot in [ __ ] cancer city
or whatever the [ __ ] it was
and uh one day my friend ryan was like i
don't need candy that
you know it was made in a factory and i
was like guess i'm [ __ ] forever on
that now
that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up he's like when
they're using beakers to make candy i'm
out and i was like god
damn i wish i [ __ ] thought of that so
instead of
wishing i thought of that i stopped
thinking that
and i thought you know what i thought of
that first
so that's mine now um
yeah you can do that you can do that
uh anyway
buggles bugles or buggles
bugles dude family size
yeah get your whole family to learn how
to like this [ __ ]
chips you know what you don't need to
ever [ __ ] change at all
chips chips or chips and that's it
there's two types of chips there's the
[ __ ] regular
chips that are potato chips and then
there's [ __ ]
mexican like tostito ones that you put
in salsa
any other [ __ ] chips go [ __ ] yourself
go
[ __ ] yourself dude you highfalutin chip
eater go [ __ ] drown dude
go drown
those baked ladies and [ __ ] in the the
what's the one that makes you diarrhea
yourself all over the place
what's the one that they recalled they
recalled one chip because they were like
okay our bad everyone [ __ ] themselves
what the [ __ ]
what were they the double baked lays
what the [ __ ] were they
lays with olestra who the [ __ ] would eat
anything called olefstra anyway
olestra dude that sounds like the
sexiest chick at a russian party
[Laughter]
hello my name is olestra and i would
like to
show you how beautiful i am
hello my name is olestra may i show you
my black light in my room
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] um olestra dude
name it something tastier
this [ __ ]
food corporations are [ __ ] they are
such [ __ ]
they are such crooks dude
and criminals they're just like they
don't even you can't if you look at the
back of a
thing at the sugar they don't even they
highlight all the [ __ ] and then they
don't highlight sugar so you won't see
it you know how [ __ ] up that is
go look the sugar is always in the
regular font that they use the regular
writing on and everything else is all in
bold
because they don't want you to know how
much sugar's in it because so much sugar
is in it because if you eat too much of
it
you'll die but they want you to eat too
much of it because they're coke
dude coca-cola i read an article once on
coca-cola
and i i read this article about this guy
who went undercover to coca-cola
meetings and [ __ ] i don't even know if
that's true
but he was like talking about coca-cola
and how he overheard one of the [ __ ]
ceos of coca-cola say
we're not trying to have more people
drink coca-cola
we're trying to put more coca-cola
into people that's what the guy [ __ ]
said meaning
he wanted more of the people he wanted
the people who drank coca-cola
to have more of that coca-cola and that
was like dude we're just [ __ ]
vessels that they want to that that that
they want to pump
their [ __ ] sugar come into
do you know what i mean they just want
to pump their sugar come into us
and we are just like i don't know and
they do it dude
because we're like hmm cool red label
that's so gross
i'm an activist
that's so gross i stopped drinking coke
that day i went cold turkey
i used to drink five six sodas a day for
real
i don't know how it was in a blimp your
boy stays lean no matter what though
he does dude he stays lean no matter
what he does
um so yeah i don't know let's get into
[ __ ] some hot [ __ ] though you know
it's like
[Music]
previously on congratulations and we
look
and we see
cenzo with a bloody mouth dude it's a
[ __ ] you know we do that bit because
it's a good bit
you know it's a fun bit we don't have
too many graphic bits but
ivan gets rid of is [ __ ] good at this
[ __ ] so we [ __ ] love him we let him
have some fun with it you know
um i don't know dude
i've been watching so many serial killer
shows i swear to god i'm gonna [ __ ]
start killing people
and like wrongfully accuse things and
it's just like so [ __ ] up man
every serial killer is like we had no
idea
bro you knew you knew i don't that's
what i don't believe
that about people all right like
if if there's a serial killer around my
circle
i'm gonna know who the [ __ ] it is i know
you're never gonna catch me with the
really well i would have never known
bro i knew okay
if somebody's like yeah but his own
people are like his own mother didn't
even
the mother was a dumb [ __ ] you know dude
okay none of my friends are [ __ ]
serial killers
i know that didn't say what i'm saying
if there was one i would know
it's just so [ __ ] obvious when
somebody's a goddamn serial killer
they just like don't say much
[Laughter]
and they like button their shirts all
the way to the top
and they have like glasses that are in
fashion now but they weren't
back when they were serial killing and
they comb their hair
way way the way they shouldn't that's a
serial killer
real simple always wearing khakis
real [ __ ] simple dude
i know if you're serial killing you
don't talk much and you do all that [ __ ]
and uh and and another thing with the
serial killers
too is like you a lot of
the people who knew that serial killer
was they would do this a lot
where's he been i haven't seen him for a
long time
because that's when he was out [ __ ]
serial killing
oh we had no idea he was always the he
was always the kind
and it was they always say this too he
was a hard worker i don't
dude that's because he had to [ __ ]
not feel bad about serial killing he
buried himself in the [ __ ]
rv rental place or whatever the [ __ ] he
worked at
also if you work at an rv rental place
there's like jobs that you if you have
you're definitely more apt to be serial
killing
rv rental you know
uh uh copy copiers like
kink you work at kinko's maybe not
kinkos but like in the 90s like a copy
place
like a mama pop copy place when they
used to have them and i hate to say it
but now [ __ ] postmates and uber eats
in 10 years i guarantee it
i guarantee it there's going to be
[ __ ] three or four post mate serial
killing ass [ __ ] we had no idea
about it now they would just come
deliver fajitas and oops in your face a
knife
oh sorry i poisoned your [ __ ]
boston market oopsy
i thought you ordered a side of poison
with your [ __ ] honey-baked ham
i thought you ordered a side of razors
with your bob's big boy
yeah dude it's obvious and i'm telling
you right now
i had uber eats and [ __ ] postmates
[ __ ] showing up and i'm just
like that dude goes serial killing i'm
just big and beefy in a tall drink of
water he knew he couldn't take me
you'll find it out in 10 years
the postmates kill the postman
the uber eats killer but one thing that
wasn't on the menu
that's what they i hate when they get
cute with all those serial killer
documentaries
or the 2020s but what she but what she
didn't order
you know what i mean
but what she didn't order it's always
that [ __ ]
billy ray stevens
billy ray stevens grew up and they
they're always in the [ __ ] marines or
the army
and they beat the serial killing into
them
it's like it's real good for your
[ __ ] uh what do they call it
you learn discipline yeah but dude did
you get i'll tell you what man
i'll tell you i'll tell you this much if
i went into the marines
i would be a [ __ ] serial killer
because there's a guy who takes
discipline well and there's a guy who
takes discipline
and then starts getting mad and then
everything else is everyone else's fault
and
that's your boy dude
wake up you know private i would be like
ah [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] 5 30 a.m wake up private and i
got to wake up but this guy's got a real
[ __ ] chip on his [ __ ] shoulder
what's that you say i didn't say
anything bro i didn't say anything
lieutenant sergeant i'm sorry
drop down and give me a hundred i can't
i can do [ __ ] 80.
clean this room with a toothbrush bro
that guy's dead when i get out you
understand what i'm saying
dead i become a [ __ ] postmates driver
in that guy's hometown
i can't wait for [ __ ] sergeant dick
face to order some fajitas
and i go oh i got as a matter of fact if
someone else gets the job before i do
i show up to the restaurant kill that
postmates driver
take the food and drive to sergeant
dickhead's house and i go
remember me and then stab him in the eye
with a [ __ ] toothbrush
discipline me now big boy that's what i
say dude
so sexual but yeah dude [ __ ] all that
there's no way they were always in the
army or the navy or the [ __ ] you know
and they they had a dog and they don't
know where it went because he tortured
it a little bit yeah he was never good
with animals
or or he was super good with animals you
know
it's never somebody that's like been in
the middle with some [ __ ]
that's my point and your boy's not in
the middle at all dude
i get mad when somebody says some [ __ ]
like you don't remember me do you when
we met
i'm enraged when someone says that
when they shake hands hey what's going
on yeah good to see you all good to see
you oh you don't remember meet me do you
oh they try to pull away oh but i'm
still holding dude
oh you thought i was gonna feel awkward
i don't [ __ ] do anything
but hold the hand still and i lean in
dude
and then i say nah i don't remember you
that's not my fault i don't remember you
be more memorable
but i have been going to therapy and
honestly a lot of this is jokes
probably more memorable but bit more
memorable you know what's weird
is though the fact that like there are
people
that just don't [ __ ] laugh at all
dude and i know i talk about this
sometimes but i can't [ __ ] believe
there are people out there that are like
wall street [ __ ]
only crunch numbers and then get off of
work and then meet
fellas for drinks and then talk numbers
and then talk about like their family
and don't really laugh that much dude
oh my dude watch youtubes of where
people slip and fall have a good time
stop crunching numbers and watch the
clip where kelsey grammer fell off the
[ __ ] theater
dude do you remember that one
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] or whatever
let's watch it kelsey grammer
feel bad for him dude it's first thing
that comes up i'm on youtube
imagine that's your [ __ ] legacy the
guy didn't
every show he did ran for 4 000 years
and the first thing that comes up on
youtube is kelsey grammer's
fr kelsey grammer's frasier falls off
stage so
disrespectful to call him to bring up
look here we go this is so great dude
through it's a small world pretending i
was a un interpreter
peter griffin so mad
i i think i'm wow
took it like a man though huh
oh wow i i think i hurt my
back yeah just
chilling dude you know what this this
guy's the man dude
that hurts so bad it just seemed like he
went in the pool
that's all it just seems like he went in
the pool oh whoa
oh it's colder than i thought
um god when i first saw that as a kid
oh my god
the antonio banderas closing the laptop
in [ __ ] the movie assassins
when i first saw that i was just like
ugh
i didn't even laugh when i saw him go
drop out of frame
i just i didn't laugh i just went
it speaks to my soul
he did 40 years he did four different
shows that ran for 40 years and this is
what he's going to be known for
what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] name is
kelsey grammer you know
that's like your [ __ ] name it's like
your name is
voltron hamburger
[ __ ] dude what does this family [ __ ]
decide
it's between kelsey grammer and voltron
hamburger
well since our last name is already
grammar why don't we go with kelsey
grammer
otherwise it would have to be voltron
hamburger grammar
voltron hamburger i'll form the bun
roll out i'll form
i'll form the i'll form the lettuce
roll out i'll form the [ __ ]
secret sauce roll out i'll form the
fries
roll out
i'll form the plate roll out i'll form
the friend's meal just keeps going
roll out i'll i'll form the waiter i'm
already
i'm actually i'll just chill i'm just i
look like i could be a waiter anyway
dude kelsey grammer falls off stage dude
anyway
uh what was i talking about oh yeah
serial killers
um so yeah dude it's obvious who the
serial killers are
i should write a [ __ ] god how much
would that be a name of a mem
of a memoir it's obvious who the secret
who it's obvious who the serial killers
are it's like a [ __ ] flowers for
algernon or some [ __ ]
oh dude some guy commented i saw and he
said man
the uh the unintentional hilarity of
crystalia's podcast and how he's losing
his mind
is [ __ ] funnier than any dude you
don't
get the joke this is what the whole
thing is
descent into madness if all
that's what it is dude that's what
everybody's doing that's what
everybody's doing and if you're not
descending into madness
you're a [ __ ] boring piece of [ __ ]
you seen al you seen al pacino
you seen him in the beginning don't ask
me about my business kate
and now he's doing movies oh yeah oh
oh yeah
he's [ __ ] nut so dude nicholas cage
he started doing movies and he was just
like i'm nicholas cage
and now he's [ __ ] have you seen the
nicholas cage movie
oh flawless everything dude he'll be a
lawyer he'll play a lawyer and in the
middle of a courtroom scene they'll just
be like
oh then you're just like what guilty
oh he's innocent oh
because he's so nicholas cage nobody is
tempering him
that's the [ __ ]
my mommy is like that
she became so much you know it's like
ladies and [ __ ]
moms become that when they talk to you
and [ __ ] and they're just like
put on your coat you're just like it's
[ __ ] summer
yeah you're gonna catch a chill
okay i guess my mom is my mom
yeah um
oh that's another one i want to add to
the soundboard the jay-z insecure laugh
we're gonna
do some soundboard [ __ ] so yeah so
serial killers man i always
you always know i'm just i'm tired of
the [ __ ]
people not knowing
i feel like when this podcast starts
when when people watch the podcast they
start the podcast
and then it and then they watch it and
then by the time the podcast is at the
end of the podcast we have like two
viewers left
um
oh i [ __ ] totally forgot i went to
get x-rays of my [ __ ] tummy remember
i told you guys i had a tummy hurt
and i went to get x-rays with the tummy
and the lady was like and the lady was
like uh
oh dude i was already yep talk about the
angry olympics man
i was at the [ __ ] uh x-ray place
second time i've been there first time
she wouldn't let me she wouldn't let me
do it because she thought
my uh insurance wasn't paid but it was
paid
okay that's it that's all you got to
know so i left dude
and i leave and i go like this i give
her my card she says
oh it's not coming up chris dele is
there any other name that it would be
under
what are you talking about hi i'm
crystalia
look that up and that works and if it
doesn't it's your fault
like what are you talk every time you
give your [ __ ] insurance card to
people they're like
okay so okay make it better insurance
cards
but it always works it always ends up
working which is the worst part because
you know you're right
you give your insurance card and then
people are like
i don't see it and you're you just
you're ready for the i don't see it
already
you give her the th your name could be
literally uh
[ __ ] you know suck
[ __ ] like the easiest thing to spell
okay so s-u-c-k s-h-i-t
is there another way to spell it and
you're like nah just suck [ __ ]
that's my name is it are you sure it's
not
c-h-i-t what am i mexican
and uh and they're like okay all right
well let me let me do you have the
social security sure yeah it's not
coming up they say
all right well just can you try again
let me try something else
okay see here it is try that
first you know what i'm talking about
it's always some [ __ ] lady with like
a tattoo on her chest
and you're just like this [ __ ] lady
has a tattoo on her chest of like the
san francisco 49ers logo
and and then you're like and then you're
like okay cool and so this time though i
went to go get the x-rays
and she was like it's not coming up
and i was like all right i'm gonna
[ __ ] drive home i'm prepared
to drive home and have it not work
so i can stir in this it didn't work the
system
failed me you know what i mean i could
stir in this
the system failed me type uh
feeling and just feel that all day
and feel like i know shit's failing out
there but i did what i had to do
i brought my insurance card to the x-ray
place
it didn't work that wasn't my fault even
though
literally this [ __ ] could be killing me
in my stomach i'm like the system failed
me
i'm good this is how i think for real
so i drove home i'm like [ __ ] it all
right cool i fire off an email
to somebody who the insurance thing i'm
like why is it not working
they send me another one so now i get
the other
new insurance card which is still the
same plan i'm all paid up everything is
fine
so now i drive down there today and i'm
like
can't wait for this one not to work i'll
drive home even
faster right
system fails me twice [ __ ] it dude i
lived a good life
and uh so i get there and i say you know
just like head wobbling so much i give
[ __ ] george clooney a run for his
money just like hey how you doing
i got my fresh insurance card i've never
used it before
first one i even had the two on you know
how to give you two attached together
i didn't detach them i had the two on
there i gave her
both of them here's one for last time
and one for this time
and i said here it is [ __ ]
her acrylic nails yeah
see the anger now
is in the middle of my chest at yeah see
yeah see it's not it's not oh yeah i
remember you coming la
yeah yeah because you said the thing
didn't work and so i got a new card and
i'm all paid up
and then over that for a fact now and so
here's my card
yeah okay she hit me with that tone
and i'm feeling good dude because i
can't wait to drive home even faster
and let the system fail me twice so i
can be right
twice
is there another way to spell your name
always with that again dude
nope it's c-h-r-i-s-d-e-l-i-a
she says okay well let me try the not do
you have social security let me try the
policy no
okay she said you know what i can try
then
i'm there [ __ ] 10 minutes i said did
you try with the
apostrophe after the d and she said the
asterisk yeah
like aaliyah was a [ __ ] typo
like aaliyah was in there in lieu of
another last name
so i was like nah it's just it yeah okay
hey look
you can call it a [ __ ] monster truck
if you want to
as long as it's dangling on the upper
half of the d
we're good and uh
she was like she was like okay um
[Music]
i said listen i said so what are we
gonna do here
i i literally i literally said that i
said so what are gonna do here
because this has worked everywhere else
and it hasn't only worked here twice now
and i've used it since the last time and
it worked
so what do we do i said and she said
i said that and she said well um
i could try something else and i said
yeah you should try that
and she said i am and i was like oh
oh we're taking steps here
we're taking steps to the octagon
you didn't have to say i am because you
already said you could try something
else
when you throw on when you tack on that
second
im you're opening the gate to the
octagon
because i just replied to your you're
doing it and i said
yeah you should try that but then when
you hit me with another
i am the only thing we're wearing
are trunks
so i calmed down i remember dude i've
been doing a lot of therapy
i think what will kristen do okay chill
well kristen i
[ __ ] didn't have time to go get a
bunch of [ __ ] presents and give to
her because that's what kristen would
have done
i got here's a loot bag
and uh
yeah and so i [ __ ]
waited and she was like she goes like
this
oh okay here it is and i s
and i said oh yeah yeah oh well yeah
that makes sense
and she was like okay so yeah here's the
deal it was
d space e-l-i-a
and i was like yeah well that should
have been something you tried probably
last week when i was here
but i guess they don't have a space for
an asterisk
anyway i went in and i got the [ __ ]
x-ray i said thank you very much i
appreciate it i know it's difficult
to get through all this [ __ ] waited
went to get the x-ray leaned on my side
the big-ass [ __ ] x-ray [ __ ]
and the nurse was sweet she was like are
you trying to be here
and and what what'd she say she was like
you don't want people to know
like she was like you don't want are you
trying to get out of here without people
noticing you it was just sweet it was
like
like she thought i was [ __ ] tom
cruise or some [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
if it's just first of all i'm a mask on
and i'm [ __ ] getting x-rays
like she thought tmz was gonna be
outside or some [ __ ] and i was like oh
it's not a big deal she's like what
and then she dude what's up with people
they just throw you for a loop sometime
i was like oh no it's fine and she was
like yeah i know who you are i was like
oh that's cool and she was like do you
have a meeting or something
and i and i and i was like oh a meeting
and she was like yeah you like have a
meeting or something and i was like
no i just
are we learning english like what is
this
do you have a meeting yes it's at
4 pm central
sometimes people just hit you with some
weird [ __ ] dude
like you're just getting the x-ray and
the nurse is like do you have a meeting
and you got to be like no
you know it's one of those things where
you literally think am i the [ __ ]
idiot here
cause this is a very basic thing to ask
somebody
do you have a meeting and it's so basic
that you already know the answer so
quickly but it has nothing to do with
anything that you've been talking about
so you're just like well the answer
can't be that
simple like i start thinking like it is
meeting a [ __ ] term for something
else
medically like that i'm in this hospital
but then i just
you don't have any answer so you're
literally just like
okay well i don't have a meeting so i'm
just gonna answer it that way and i just
say
no you know what i mean
one time i was driving late at night
i was in high school and this
i i see the sirens on the up in the back
of of my car
a policeman is pulling me over
and i'm like wow i don't know what i was
doing wrong you know sometimes you trick
yourself into thinking
i don't know what i'm doing wrong but
you know you're a little bit speeding or
you were texting or what this was before
cell phones and uh
he pulls me over and i'm like all right
i don't know what i did i really don't
and he says he i rolled the window down
a cop rolls up he says
hey and i said hey and he says
um
do you know why i pulled you over and i
said uh
no i i i don't was i s was i
speeding and he said no
and i said oh okay
and he said well i pulled you over
because you were driving
this is what he said and i quote he says
you were driving rather
gingerly
and i took a beat and i
i thought okay well
that's okay because uh
that's not bad and then i took another
beat
and i actually thought do i know what
gingerly means
and i said to him i said
that's okay right and he said oh yeah
it's very okay
and now i'm like am i in twin
peaks because i don't understand what's
happening
and i said oh okay
and he said sometimes
if people have had too much to drink
they drive very carefully
and i said oh okay well i haven't had
anything to drink and he said i could
see that now
and i said okay so i was just driving
carefully
and he said yeah he said well have a
good day and be safe getting home
and i was like okay the weirdest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever
but sometimes people just throw you for
a [ __ ] loop dude
with these questions and i remember
right as the window was closing
he stopped and turned around and he said
do you have a meeting
[Laughter]
anyway dude i guess that's it this was
fun man i told you it's fun
doing this podcast because i [ __ ]
forget these things that happened in my
life like that thing with that cop
i totally haven't thought about that in
years and sometimes i think of [ __ ] all
the time like there was another story i
told you i think all the time
of my buddy ryan when he said the thing
about what was it
the king candy the candy yeah the candy
in a factory yeah
um yeah i think about that all the time
but yeah it's good to share those
stories with you and also the ones that
[ __ ] make me think of
them when i'm in because when i do this
podcast i only had like let's see one
two three things to talk about
and um sometimes i like to do that
because it makes me nervous
like i don't have enough to talk about
and then when i do it it
i'm in like this fight or flight mode to
where it's like i have to come up with
other [ __ ]
you know i do this on stage a lot too
like i'll go up with one idea and i'll
just start talking about it but
it it's it's a lot of fun doing this
podcast because i know i have to fill at
least in
whatever [ __ ] hour or something of
stuff and then so i start thinking about
other things it's really fun to do so i
really appreciate you guys i really
appreciate you guys listening to this
um so yeah dude uh i'll close it up by
saying thanks for uh the uh
all the patreon love it's been really
[ __ ] sweet and uh
don't forget to [ __ ] gently graze up
against that subscribe button
and gently graze up against that like
button and also
when if you're there you know just kind
of gently throw a warm breeze over to
the [ __ ] bell notifications you know
just [ __ ] do you know what i mean i'd
like you to [ __ ]
just just saunter on over to the
subscribe button and just see what it
feels like right there
and then all you got to do is just kind
of
maybe do a little hop skip and a jump
over to the [ __ ]
and just take a just take a look at the
at the
uh at the like button just take a nice
meaningful look at the like button
and then i when you're on your way over
there just [ __ ] crop dust the bell
notifications i'd i'd love that man
thank you very much
hey guys that's the end of the episode
but head on over to our patreon
uh and you can see
the rest of the episode which is
patreon.com
crystalia go check out the rest of the
episode at patreon.comcrystalia
and you can also check out all of the
backlog of the hidden episodes that
aren't available on youtube only on our
patreon
and other bonus content too but uh and
you're supporting
supporting the show so thanks very much
[Music]
hey what's up what's up guys yeah i'm
not gonna do that
anyway let's go what's up guys